and i ask this selfishly because i'm
trying to balance it out like i got
beyonce this guy's time management's
crazy yeah like i'm literally picking
your brain for like my
hopeful future but like you know like
you you know you have to be skating x
amount of hours in order to keep your
[ __ ] to learn new tricks to keep all
these other [ __ ] nipping at
your heels at bay but at the same time
you got a family you got kids i don't
feel that pressure anymore with the
family or with them no no
no
that's the trick
why you should try that no that's still
hey well
you should my wife and i we have six
kids and five are out of the house oh
okay okay so three year in college two
are just grown ass men and
um
and so
but but to answer your question that
that pressure never ends really we're
still helping our kids
just be adults
you know to navigate life like that that
never really is you keep stay apparent
even if they're not in the house but um
i don't feel the pressure to be so on
point skating because
why what about early on like when you
were in the middle um yeah i did but but
i but i just loved it so that i was
doing it by default
i wasn't training
interesting you know i just i just loved
i loved creating new tricks i loved in
fact when i was competing i felt like i
was stifled because i i couldn't
go out and try crazy new stuff because i
might get hurt or
i um
might do something like i might learn a
trick and then want to do it the next
time at the contest and probably too
risky at that point yeah yeah yeah yeah
so the fun part of skating was taking
it's kind of similar to stand-up like i
don't want to give seinfeld credit for
this because he's annoying but like uh
mark was saying that like seinfeld said
that uh that he likes skateboarders
because they're like comics
and and what was the exact thing it was
like they just keep trying something and
it fails almost every time and
eventually it works and then it's a
great feeling when it works but i felt
that way when i was preparing for for uh
for this special that we just did i was
just like uh sometimes i just want to go
up and say something maybe a [ __ ]
bomb so maybe it's good then i'll find
some new little portal into something
else but when you're trying to lock down
every single word
for a special exactly yeah it's the same
thing yeah you can't take that exact
risk
yeah yeah it ruins the freedom a little
bit
yeah absolutely but even with like
family and that kind of stuff there was
never an issue you're like yeah i got to
go skate there was never like oh we need
to have some time together um i
probably through the early 2000s the
heydays of my video game i
i might have um
chosen skating or events uh over
being a parent
that didn't bode well uh with
relationships either but um yeah yeah i
definitely i i got caught up in it did
you develop like a good excuse
turn around look at the house and be
like you want me to stay home or you
want me to no
never mind my girl and i got a big fight
last night and during the whole fight
she didn't know that you're coming on
today and i was like oh she don't even
[ __ ] know where i'm about to drop on
her
i didn't [ __ ] know like i was a
little bit late because i'm prepared and
i work
and she's upset that i'm late without
knowing why i'm late and i just subtly
threw it out there i was like i was like
yeah listen i'm sorry you know repairing
you know tony hawk's coming on tomorrow
and i just saw her like eyes like light
up in the middle of the fight and i was
like yeah you're done
you've got nothing on me now they never
thought i'd be using ammunition like
that
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know i'm always curious
about that like people have went through
well i don't know i think you're very
humble about it but i think that what
you've been well i came from i came from
a world that was largely shunned and you
were made fun of explain that because i
don't think even my generation
understood the idea that like you were
bullied for skateboarding like that
didn't exist absolutely yeah by whom
like
i imagined by anyone my age really yeah
because because when you in the in the
late 70s early 80s
skating
had
been through a fad phase so it was it
was like a toy it was like a frisbee
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i got a yo-yo
that was it because it was really yo-yo
frisbee yeah yeah that was it
skateboards and then and then i saw
something else in skateboarding because
i i went i got to go to skatepark and i
was young and i saw people flying around
i want to do that yeah and when i dove
into it headfirst
like that literally at first time
um
the fad was over
and so when i was walking through high
school especially early like junior high
and high high school
scanning is like still skate
oh it was antiquated yeah it was just
like well aren't you too old for that
i'm
14. it's like a pogo stick or something
absolutely like in high school we're
playing with pogs i used to hide
i used to hide my skateboard in the
bushes no before school because if i
carried around school then i was just
marked
and i would get hassle and so
through those years and and then
at some point it started to come back
around back to the future app
uh back to the future happened and the
skating started to get back in the fold
and then
by then i was sort of in my later years
of high school and so people knew that a
pro skater went to their high school but
they couldn't pick me up
wow so here you see you're already
professional you're already
very successful
yeah let's make it i owned a house when
i was a senior in high school that's
crazy
and none of them knew that that's what
you were doing you had to hide it from
him well that was like being gay at that
point
back in the day right now be like hey
mom i skate okay mom i ride wood
i used to get uh if i so i do remember
carrying my skateboard through the
parking lot and a dude yelling skater
[ __ ] no no
like repeatedly just like okay dude i
get it
it's a long parking lot yeah and he's
driving through
of course of course of course but it's
the same but but yeah
yeah no no that's
feelings no facts yeah but okay so then
there's this turn right i remember
rollerblading got popular all of a
sudden yeah and then like
okay that was more
mid 90s so this is already after so
rollerblade yeah so skateboarding came
and went like
late 80s okay again more as a fad but
but a little more established yeah and
so people were
it i think that people held on to it
longer and that it sort of
they love the attitude the skating they
love the sort of diy and that it was
different
and stuff like that yeah so so there's a
lot of people especially now who skated
in those days and they
they credit skating for their approach
to life
but then doctor he would have 100 say
the same thing
but then when he died
when he died like in popularity again
because all the skateparks were closing
they couldn't afford insurance
people started
taking to the streets but just was less
popular rollerblading was on the rise
and i credit rollerblading for
for supplementing my income because i
got invited as the special guest to a
bunch of roller blade shows
oh [ __ ]
yeah i remember that so there'd be you
know there'd be like
for instance uh
there were um some demos happening skate
exhibitions in the parking lot of six
flags
and it was because of rollerblade
and so there's all these pro
rollerbladers and they would invite me
like hey special guest skateboarder tony
hawk and then matt hoffman special guest
bmx writer so he and i were like the
the outliers yeah yeah but getting paid
so we're like okay
yeah sign me up now
i think some people credit this one
almost like dad joke for rollerblading
dying do you believe that it's true
it's like what's the hardest part about
what is it what is the joke what's the
heart
oh yeah what's the hardest part about
rollerblading uh telling your dad you're
gay yeah
i i truly do believe
that joke killed rollerblading
[Laughter]
i really dude like i because i had
roller blades and i heard that joke once
and i looked at him i was like i don't
have to tell my dad yet
[Applause]